GQ magazine is redefining the definition
of masculinity in this me to era for
November's new masculinity issue
interviews with Pharrell Williams NBA
star Kevin Love and comedian and Daily
Show correspondent that is jubu ki young
white they look at how men's behavior
it's changing young white shares his
experience is here's experience rather
as a member of the LGBTQ community he
uses humor to tackle tough topics like
gun control and skits on The Daily Show
we don't need gun control we just need
to decrease gun ownership okay but how
do you decrease gun ownership without
gun control laws easy Trevor we just
need to make guns gay
[Applause]
as far as I know guns don't have a
sexual orientation well not at the
moment Trevor not yet but I just read
this study that says a lot of straight
men don't recycle because they're
worried it makes them look gay so we
just need to harness that same toxic
masculinity and just direct it toward
guns you know sweet gay guns there he is
first on CBS this morning Djibouti young
white and GQ editor in chief that's will
Welch joining us at the table welcome to
you both gentlemen thank you so much I
want to start with you will because I
love when you got the job most people
said Congrats yay Bravo and you had one
friend that said yikes
hell of a time to be editor-in-chief of
a men's magazine and you took that to
mean what yeah I took it as a sort of a
reality check yeah and she was throwing
the gauntlet saying this is like this is
exciting it's a big role congratulations
but this is serious work because you
said what is men's role in what you call
this shut up and listen era yeah
absolutely
your take yeah and this the new
masculinity issue which came out
yesterday we very very provocative cover
there's a provocative got to get
people's attention in this environment
of it yeah it is really stunning we
started working on this issue in January
and that's partially because it is sort
of this shut up and listen moment where
people don't women especially don't want
men just like barging in like we're
gonna fix this and we take that aspect
seriously so we wanted to take our time
with it do it right and really get all
the dials set in the right place so
we're proud of the result I guess what
reexamining masculinity is not only good
for women it's good for men it's for
free exercise and you've got in your
interview jumuchi a comment that I
thought really hit home which is it for
many men the way they learn masculinity
is through getting it beaten into them
it's kind of scar on their identity you
talked a bit about that yeah absolutely
I think that so many of us the traits
that we pick up in our childhood are
things that not that we maybe didn't
naturally gravitate toward but we were
taught no this is the way that it's
supposed to be and you sort of correct
yourself over time and build on what
that natural impulse was to just like
express yourself you talked about what
you heard her dad's barber shop for
example yeah which is a bastion of male
of masculinity a black barbershop
yes been there many times yeah yeah I
remember when the Dangerously in Love
video dropped and I was like doing
choreo and they were like you can't do
that why can't I do this the choreo is
Papa's like what would I know
yeah I think that it was stuff like that
where I feel like for me how many times
of not being straight I was just like
okay well I'm already existing outside
of this so a lot of this doesn't apply
to me I can just pick and choose but
there are a lot of people who still feel
the pressure to and hear to every single
thing that they're well they need to be
in well you did a survey with a thousand
men and women about the state of
masculinity what didn't you find well
the first thing is that 97 percent of
respondents said that they've noticed
that masculinity is changing so this is
real this is happening it's not
something we made up out of thin air
yeah the other thing that stuck out to
me is 30% of men said that they were
confused by the changes and that was a
real call to action for me and for the
team at GQ for me the new masculine it's
very simple it's I Know Who I am and I
respect who you are it comes down to
that yeah I'm aware I'm free to express
myself I also respect djibouti's right
to express himself I wouldn't ever put
my needs
I wouldn't project those on him and I
asked the same thing in return
yeah that's what I wouldn't want to know
when you say changing changing how yeah
that vulnerability is okay is one of the
things that you point out in a magazine
I'm Slater not raised that way yeah and
this this project is ongoing for us so
it's something that we've been touching
on all year then we did a whole issue
around it that's out now and we're gonna
continue to do it so last issue Brad
Pitt and his cover story was talking
about growing up in the Ozarks not
feeling free to be in touch with his
feelings and the process of becoming an
adult for him has been about learning to
be vulnerable [ __ ] male anchors have to
wear suits on TV asking for a friend go
I felt that I should wear one today out
of respect for Gale otherwise I think
it's a free-for-all you
the yellow boat yes shiny
try the